Prince Harry and Megan Markel's wedding
invitations are out and women have been
advised to wear quote Day dress with hat
so this week it's all about what's on
your head on spillin the royalty put me
in a hat shop and things will get a
little mad but since I'm going to
England to cover Prince Harry and Megan
markle's wedding in May I had to learn
what's appropriate to wear yes you have
to have a hat you can't go to the royal
wedding without a hat I found an expert
this is Louise Greene she's a colorful
delight and she'll make your hat just
right her Los Angeles space is one of
the few of its kind left over the top
hats are custom made to order in house
she and her craftspeople are still using
sewing machines from the 1920s oh and
they're definitely not okay with me
touching them louise is even from London
herself and because today is all about
getting things British and proper this
isn't just a hat shop help me make sure
that I'm saying this right Louise Greene
millinery No
how do you like millinery millinery yes
a millinery and you are a milliner /
this milliner aka professional hat maker
there are many do's and don'ts for royal
wedding where you have to cover your
shoulders dresses are down to the knee
there's not gonna be anything
provocative in dressing but then they
can go wild with the hats that hat well
people only be wearing fascinators at
the wedding like I don't really know if
I'm gonna be wearing hats and they will
be wearing fascinators fascinator is a
small hat usually it's a headpiece so it
will be affixed to the head either with
a headband or a comb or an elastic and
it covers like part of the head whereas
a hat covers the forehead there are sort
of rules in the church it wouldn't be
polite to be wearing a huge hat in the
church because then you'd be blocking
someone's view behind you or a few
people's view
what's your creative process so I will
tell I'll ask them first of all if they
have their outfit do they want to bring
an outfit in or do they want to do the
Hat first most people bring the outfit
in we'll try on different shapes
different materials and then I will
start bringing things out from the
studio you know different trims
different colors until we're we're
really happy and I'll make the base of
the Hat and then we'll pin on trims and
then the custom will come back for a
fitting and once she's happy then we'll
yeah then we'll go ahead and make the
Hat it's usually how many fittings oh
just one yes it's different you know you
don't like lose or gain weight in your
head it's not like a dress I know but
there is a big thing oh yeah I mean if
somebody has really thick hair like I do
and then I have a haircut then my hats
fit differently so we have to know how
they're gonna wear their hair okay you
know that's really important so if you
like with you you have long hair you
couldn't put your hair up in a ponytail
here right because the Hat wouldn't fit
on so you'd put like if you were gonna
put a high ponytail you put low one here
if you have your hair like this which is
probably how you're usually wearing if
you put a hat on this is gonna look like
curtains it's just gonna be stuck like
that so you'd either put it you could
put it to the side like this and then
put the hat on
or you'd pull it all the way back louise
has already gotten calls from a select
few here in the US who are attending the
wedding and need hats her creations
range from a few hundred dollars up to
more than a thousand depending on
materials and detailing and big news she
is going to give me a hat to wear to
England we tried a few on wow the ways I
thought this was gonna look crazy but I
actually feel great okay now we've got
feathers do people judge each other on
the hands of course and but but it's a
conversation piece people are very happy
you know they're very happy and it's
easier to meet people when you're
wearing a hat like
something to talk about yeah love yeah
amazing and I can just whack people with
the feathers and they're annoying me
you're gonna be photographed a lot then
or even at just a couple of shots you
don't want to cover your eyes you want
to keep away from your eye I want to be
photographed missus is gonna look
gorgeous on you oh yes okay we're on
another level now and that is so
appropriate it's lively and fun it goes
with your outfit it's not matchy-matchy
and it looks terrific I mean this side
is giving me like garden gorgeousness
this side is giving me like the flower
has bloomed it's open yes yes yes Louise
we cannot wait to see what people wear
on the big day and I want to know what
you guys think I should wear let me know
I'll keep you posted on what Louise
makes for me
[Music]
I've always hated my head it's very
large we measure it before you're late